PAUL KINLAN: Hi everyone.
I'm Paul Kinlan.
Welcome to our talk today,
called How to Build Apps that
Love Each Other.
JAMES HAWKINS: Hi, I'm James.
I'm the tech lead of the Chrome
team working to bring
Web Intents to the web.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So, before we start, I
just want to ask one
little quick question.
Actually, two questions.
Who has heard of Web Intents?
JAMES HAWKINS: All right.
PAUL KINLAN: Awesome.
Who has was actually built
anything with Web Intents?
JAMES HAWKINS: That's awesome.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah, two people.
Two or three people, cool.
So, hopefully by the end of this
presentation, you'll all
be able to go away and start
building things with this work
that we call Web Intents.
And today we're going to show
you some awesome stuff.
So, today, before we start,
I'm going to highlight a
couple of problems.
For me, the biggest problem
that we face on the web is
that there's no way for
applications on the web to
understand the functionality
that other applications offer.
And because we can't do this,
we can't do really cool
things, such as offer suggested
services for you to
use when you want to perform
an action on the web.
But it also means our web
applications today, they don't
love each other.
Applications are a lot
like a relationship.
Well, they're not like a lot
But they're built off the
background of a really strong
communication.
A great relationship is built
off strong communication, and
likewise, web applications
should be able to love each
other through strong
communication.
So let's start with an image.
An image is something that
we manipulate every day.
We do things, we email them,
we edit them, we do crazy
amounts of things with images.
So let's have a go.
JAMES HAWKINS: Hopefully
this looks OK.
PAUL KINLAN: There we are.
Cool.
So that we captured our image,
Right so let's do
some stuff with it.
Well, the first thing that most
people want to do with an
image on the web, you want to
actually bring it in to your
application.
And everyone in this room, if
you're a web developer or a
user, you're probably familiar
with this button.
It's the input box.
It's input type equals file.
And this actually works
really well.
It works really well because
one, it's simple to implement.
But the second reason why it
works quite well is it's
actually pretty easy
to users to use.
They will choose a file, scan
the hard drive, and load it
into their application.
The complexity arises, though,
when you have multiple
applications which all
manipulate images and you want
to bring that data from
one app to another.
So the process of getting, say,
an image into Gmail from,
say, a site like Flickr, is that
you normally have to go
to Flickr, right click
on the image,
download it to your desktop.
Everyone in this room's probably
got a temporary
downloads folder which is
probably a good couple hundred
megabytes in size, thousands
of files inside there.
Anyway.
You've downloaded your file
into this folder.
You then jump back your email
application, click attach.
Try and find the file, because
it's not always in last place
you actually found the file
the previous time around.
And then you bring it back
into your application.
For users, this is it's a bit
of a nightmare, right?
We can't build applications
coherently with this method.
So let's have a look at
another use case.
Edit an image.
It's a very similar process.
You have an application--
this is Psykopaint--
you have an application, you
want to bring data into it.
So it's the same
process again.
You have to load this
application up.
And if it's in another app
already, if it's on Flickr,
you have to download it onto
your desktop, jump into this
app, click Open, bring
it into the app.
Then there's an extra step.
Once you've edited this image,
you have to then go and save
it again to the desktop.
So you've now got two
copies in your
temporary downloads folder.
Jump back your previous app, and
then upload and attach it.
We shouldn't have to face
these problems.
Users shouldn't find
this complexity.
And as developers, we don't have
nice ways of integration.
It's all very manual work.
Some services offer direct
API integrations.
The problem with direct API
integrations is-- we've all
seen this before, OAuth--
all these different types
of complexities with
authentication, server-to-server
communication.
These applications don't work
very well when you're offline
because you need to talk to
a server to give another
application data.
It's horrible for developers and
it's not nice for users.
Likewise, if you have an image,
and you've edited it,
and you want to save it to make
sure it's all backed up.
Well, you normally want to save
it to your desktop or
maybe to your cloud
storage solution.
Right now, if you're developing
something and you
want to save it to, well, in
this case, Drive, it's a
direct API integration that
you have to build.
Which is complex
because there's
authentication protocols.
Once there's authentication
protocols, they're actually
pretty hard to debug because
working the clients is
different to the work that you
do in the server, and it's
really hard to debug those
two types of systems.
And obviously we've got
things like OAuth.
OAuth is relatively easy once
you get the hang of it, but
it's actually complex
to get started.
And we don't want to have to
deal with that on the web.
And then, once you've saved it,
and you're happy with the
fact that you've got a nice back
up, you want to send it
out somewhere.
You want to send your image
to your grandmother.
Now, we face two problems on the
web-- or I think we face
two problems on the
web, at least.
We have a temporary solution, a
solution that already exists
on the web called mail2.
The mail2 scheme.
Now that works quite well, but
when you've got an application
that doesn't know your entire
contact address book or your
social networking, your social
graph, well, your application
won't know the recipients that
you want to send the data to.
Which means, well, how'd you
actually know that you're
going to send something
to your grandmother?
Because the mail2 link
will be blank.
It's pretty complex.
And then the second part this
problem is mail2 works pretty
well if you want to attach a
subject, a title, and some
basic description to an email.
Browsers have got that pretty
much locked down for trying to
do that type of stuff.
But we have an image.
This is a real blob of data.
How do we get our real blob of
data from our site directly
into another application?
We can't do with the
existing protocols.
And then, if you look at the way
that users have to do this
today, well, it's exactly the
same process, the same set of
steps that we saw before.
The user takes their data from
another application, downloads
it into a temporary store,
goes back to this email
application, clicks attach.
It's a really familiar process,
and it's just not
great for users.
And users don't like the app.
They kind of like the apps that
we're going, but we can
make our applications
a lot better.
And then we looked at the idea
of send an email like a
one-to-one communication.
Everyone knows this use case.
The ability to share some piece
of data with multiple
different types of
social networks.
Well, at this mention that
there's at least three hundred
different types of
sharing services.
So what's that mean for you
as a web developer?
Well, you can't feasibly
integrate with all 300
different types of services
so you can use and
aggregate the service.
But the problem is, the way that
these applications are
built, and the way you interact
with these APIs,
there's normally two methods.
There's a widget and a
server-to-server integration.
Widgets are great.
You can just drop
a small piece of
JavaScript on your page.
But the problem that it
introduces is every time you
add an extra widget, your
page load is delayed.
It gets longer and longer
and longer.
And each widget that you put
into your application is a
tight coupling to
that service.
Not great, because you might
have users that don't use the
services that you're offering.
If you have unhappy users, you
might have no users at some
point in the future.
And then the next is
server-to-server integration.
We have these services where
we can send data to another
service just by doing an
OAuth authenticated
request to the server.
The problem with this
is it's relatively
complex to do OAuth.
It's hard to maintain, it's
very hard to debug.
You never actually quite know
if you've got the problem
yourself with the way that
you've done the integration,
or whether it's the other
service so that's got a
temporary problem.
It's just a bit of
a pain to debug.
And, obviously, it requires
an internet connection.
If you want to send a status
update to a social network,
you have to have an internet
connection to be able to
deliver data between these two
apps and two services.
It's not easy, right?
This is me, I'm really
unhappy.
I'm a developer and
I'm also user.
For me, as a developer, I don't
want to have to maintain
all these direct integrations.
If a new service comes out, I
don't want to have to keep
adding more and more and
more integrations.
And, likewise, if a service dies
and no longer exists, I
have to keep track of all
these services that add.
I don't want to have to maintain
and remove all the
services as they come
into life and leave.
And as a user, I want choice.
I want to be able to use the
services I want to for common
actions across the web.
So if I want to share to a
particular social network, I
should be allowed to do that.
If I want to save some data
to my cloud, I should
be able to do that.
And I don't think, to date,
we can easily do that.
So what can we do?
What would it look like if we
could build a solution that
was better?
Well, ideally, it would
be client-side first.
Everyone, probably, in this
room is probably quite
familiar with this.
This isn't the solution, this
is some of the problem.
We have two applications that
live inside the browser.
And to get data from one
application to another
application, we have to send
data from our client
application to our application
server.
The application server has to
communicate with the remote
service server, potentially do
some authentication protocols
and some authentication work to
actually make sure the user
is sending the data
to the service.
And then the user will open up
the other site, which will
then talk to that application
service.
This is actually kind
of brittle, right?
If any one of these points goes
down, we have got two
applications that can't
talk to each other.
It's pretty complex.
So ideally, we have these two
applications inside the browser.
We should be able to open up
one application, open up
another application, then just
deliver data from one app to
the other without having to
go across the internet.
And this is really cool, because
once we can do these
types of things, we can start to
build truly offline-enabled
applications.
So has anyone use Appcache?
A couple of people.
We all know that Appcache is
actually pretty hard to work
with and pretty hard to debug,
pretty hard to maintain.
But it actually starts
to make our
applications available offline.
The problem is, right now if
you want to integrate with
another service, even if that
other service is Appcache
enabled and works offline, you
still need the whole internet
connection to be able to deliver
data to the app.
And what we're saying is, for a
lot of actions such as, say,
editing an image, you shouldn't
have to require on a
whole internet connection just
deliver data between these two
applications.
So, with a solution that we want
to try and propose, it
should work, and it should
enable you to build
applications that
work offline.
And ideally, it should
be loosely coupled.
This is the best image
I could find that
wasn't a class diagram.
The idea is we should be able to
use any particular clients
with any particular service.
And that it should be
down to the user
to use those services.
The user should be able to say,
I'm going to use Google
or Twitter to actually
share some data.
Rather than us, as developers
of the client applications,
enforcing that upon
the user, right?
That's what we want
from a solution.
And, ideally, it should handle
the user's intents.
This is, obviously, the name
of Web Intents, right?
The user should say, I need
to edit an image.
The user has a set task that
they're going to do with
something on the web.
They need to edit an image.
They need to edit an image
with their preferred
application.
They need to share
a link with their
preferred social network.
They need to save a document to
their preferred cloud file
storage solution.
The user always wants to do
something in the browser with
the data that your applications
are producing,
and you should be able
to let them do
that with a good solution.
And ideally it should
be familiar.
It should be familiar to
millions of users.
Millions of users using Android
system are familiar
with the ability to actually
find applications to fulfill
common actions on that device.
And ideally, for developers, the
API should look relatively
similar what--
I don't know how many
developers are--
it should actually look
relatively similar to the APIs
that are offered on the systems
that already exist.
So introducing Web Intents.
Obviously, we've given the name
away up front, about this
is a talk about Web Intents.
But this is our proposed
solution for actually enabling
you to integrate with remote
services any service that you
want to that supports
the APIs.
So what is a Web Intent?
It isn't the next generation of
internet-enabled camping equipment.
I'm really sorry for
that one, guys.
It is a client-side framework
that allows users to use their
preferred applications for
actions on content-types.
The really exciting thing
right now is that we're
actually working with a W3C,
and we're at first public
working draft, which is the
first step to standardization.
We still got quite a way to go,
but we've actually got an
experimental build inside
Chrome, and we're going to
show you that today if you've
not seen it and
already played with it.
And we're going to show you some
of the things that you
can do with that.
So it's pretty cool.
So how does it work?
We'll start with a demo.
But before we jump into the
demo, I want to show you some
of the source code.
So the application that we've
built is roughly about 40
lines of code, and we're going
to have the option to interact
with four different
types of services.
This is a powerful
thing for me.
You don't have to think about
how you're going to integrate
with services to be able
to start talk to them.
If you don't have to think about
that, then you can just
concentrate on the things
that you do best.
So let's just jump back to our
application and show you a
demo in action.
So this is an application we've
built called Imagemator.
It's not an amazingly
complex application.
All it does is allow
you to orchestrate
operations on images.
So the first thing that we need
to do is pick an image.
This is the picker,
the intent picker.
We've got a couple of
services on top.
These are services that we've
installed, and suggestions on
the bottom.
The suggestions come from
the Chrome Web Store.
The really important thing about
this is we don't want
the users to ever be without a
service that can fulfill that
action, which is why the Chrome
Web Store is integrated
into this solution.
So let's choose Cloud
File Picker.
Cloud File Picker is another
application that we've built
as a demo application that
allows us to bring images in
from our Picasa account.
It's pretty cool.
So we've seen Google Glass,
it's pretty cool.
I invented Google Glass
two years ago.
It kind of worked.
Admittedly--
[LAUGHTER]
It kind of worked, right?
The resolution wasn't great.
It wasn't 3D, though, that's
the good thing, right?
JAMES HAWKINS: He's not
lying, this picture is
actually two years old.
So I think he came
up with it first.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So we brought in data from a
remote application into our
application.
Both of our applications, they
don't know about each other,
but they can talk to each other
and work with each other
like they do.
So let's just try
one more thing.
Let's edit the image.
So the important thing to
remember about Intents, for
me, at least--
my favorite part of this-- is we
don't have to build a full
image editing suite.
We can build an application
which just is quite
specialized in one
particular task.
And Mememator is an
example of this.
Mememator is just a little
service that adds funny text
to interesting pictures.
So let's add some
text to this.
JAMES HAWKINS: All right.
[APPLAUSE]
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you.
We didn't actually do that
one in practice.
Cool.
So this is really cool, right?
We've got two different
applications, two remote
services, one client
application, and they've all
been able to talk
to each other.
And yet they don't know
about each other.
They only know about the types
of services that each
application offers.
I think that's pretty
powerful.
So just to briefly go over
how it works again.
We have a client application,
and the user basically asks of
the browser, find me a list of
applications that support the
ability to, say edit an image,
or pick an image in this case.
The browser will resolve the
list of either install
services, offer a list of
suggestions as well,
potentially, and then deliver
the data client-side--
so we're not going through
the internet service--
deliver the data client-side
into the application.
The user will do the work and
then pass the data back again
on the client-side without
having to go through servers,
back into the client
application.
And that's exactly what we've
just seen with Imagemator.
JAMES HAWKINS: So.
By now, you must be thinking
to yourself, wow, this is
really compelling.
I can integrate with another
application and not have to
know what that application
actually is.
So how to integrate your
application with Intents with
some other service?
In Web Intents parlance, the
service is the end point that
provides functionality
that a client
application can request.
So here we have a couple
of services.
We have an image editor that
is exposing the edit
functionality.
We also have a cloud storage
application which is exposing
two functionality
that it can do.
It can save images to the cloud
and it can also allow
clients to pick images
from the storage.
So it's actually really
simple to integrate.
You don't have to
do very much.
First, you have to declare what
your service app can do.
What functionality
do you expose?
We have high-level verbs such
as picking, editing, sharing
that you say, this
is what I can do.
After that, you just
accept the payload
data from the client.
And perhaps do some
manipulation, perform the
function that you said you can
do, and then potentially send
data back to the client.
So as you can see here, we
have two solutions for
integrating with Intents.
The first is what you can
get in the current,
stable version of Chrome.
Right now, Chrome apps can
register that they handle
Intents using their
app manifest.
So we have an Intent section
which you can list of the
different intents that
you can handle.
We have the action of saving,
we can save types of images,
and we've got a couple other
attributes which I'll talk
about later.
One of the cool things that we
can do-- and Paul talked about
this a little bit--
with Chrome app Manifest, is
that we can use the Chrome web
store to sort of curate and
expose these services, these
applications to the browser when
the client requests some
functionality.
So, as we view Save here.
If a client ever says, I need
a save service, we go to the
Chrome Web Store and say, hey,
give us a list of potentially
the high-ranking services that
provide, say, functionality.
And then we can show this to the
user, even if they don't
have these applications
installed.
So it's really good
for discovery for
the user, as well.
But in the web, it's not really
great if only Chrome
Apps can handle Intents.
We want this available
everywhere.
So you'll see at the bottom
here, we've got this new HTML
tag-like thing.
Well, that's exactly
what it is.
This is the Intent tag, which
we've introduced as a proposal
for the addition to HTML, which
will allow all web pages
to register their service,
their page, as a service.
So let's go into a little bit of
detail about the attributes
that you want to be able to
choose for your service.
The first major one is the
action that you can handle.
So you'll notice here that we've
got webintents.org/save.
That's a URL.
To be fair, the spec states that
the action is actually
just a string literal.
It could be any string.
But we feel it's really
important to set precedents
with URLs for a couple
of reasons.
The biggest one is that
documentation.
Paul, thank you.
So, here we have
webintents.org/save.
This site says exactly how you
should call, as a client, this
action, and what you need to do
as a service to implement
this functionality.
It shows the inputs that you may
receive for this section
and outputs as well.
We've also got a nice little
way to demo it here, too.
So we are demo-ing the save.
We have Cloud File
Picker installed.
It's pretty neat.
Yeah.
We have these high-level actions
that we provided on
WebIntents.org.
Things that we think most
applications will want to
integrate with.
But let's say that you have your
own application, and you
have some functionality that's
very compelling that you want
other sites to be able
to use, other clients
to be able to use.
Well, you should be able
to expose that as well.
Let's say that my web
page is example.com.
So I have some functionality,
let's call it transform.
So I want to share this
with the world.
So my action will be
example.com/transform.
Developers can go to that
URL, where you have the
documentation for this action,
the inputs and outputs that
you need, and clients can
integrate with this.
We have a much better world.
The next attribute we'll want
to talk about is the Type.
So the Type is the type of
data that you can handle.
For the Save action, we're
saying we handle
saving types of images.
And I'll go into a little bit of
detail about what the type
actually means.
Here, we have a MIME type.
Images with wild carding,
in fact.
So we're saying we can
handle all images.
But you could also list an
array of MIME types.
So let's say you edit images,
but you don't want to say to
the world, I can handle editing
all types of images,
because there might be some
formats that you don't
actually handle.
So you could specify a list.
Say, image/ping, image/jpg,
and probably image/bitmap,
though I don't know who
would be using that on
the web these days.
Note that, while you can use
MIME types, you can also use
string literals here, too.
I don't know if you've ever
heard of schema.org, but
schema.org is this sort of
next-generation semantic web
where they expose nouns.
Schema.org/imageobject is a
reference for what an image
object might actually contain.
Attributes about images.
So you could say, I don't want
to specify MIME type, I want
to specify schema.org/image.
And then clients and services
will integrate around this
point on schema.org.
It doesn't have to be
schema.org, it could be any
string literal.
But you can see it's really
expandable to whatever you
need to use here.
So these next two attributes
are going to
talk about are optional.
And I'll go into a little bit of
detail about what it means
if you don't actually
specify it.
So href is the page that's
actually going to be invoked
by the browser whenever your
service is invoked.
So for this Save action, we're
saying, don't open my main
page, my index.html,
if you will.
Open my save.html, which is the
page where I have specific
functionality to handle
this service.
So on the Intent tag, it's
important to notice for web
pages that the intent tag will
say, save.html off of your
domain where you're
registered?
So you could have users visit
your main homepage and
register for services at all
these different pages off of
your main site.
It is same origin, for security
reasons, obviously.
So you can't go register for
ABC.com, some service there,
to send them Intent data.
Last attribute we're going to
talk about is disposition.
So currently, we have
two dispositions
that you can specify.
We feel that services know
best how they should be
displayed, whether you want to
take up maximum screen real
estate or you feel
it's good to be--
your UI's very concise and small
and maybe you want to
have reference of the page,
the client page.
So, one of the dispositions
you can use is window.
Window, in the Chrome browser,
at least, opens up your
service in a new tab.
This is really important, like
I said, for when you really
want to maximize screen
real estate.
An image editor, for example,
really should not be
constrained to a small window.
You want to make the
most of that.
We also have the inline
disposition.
And in Chrome, the inline
disposition actually shows up
in the Pick your UI.
So once you select, say, Shorten
with Google, then you
see the service actually show
up inside this picker.
The picker will mold to the
size of the content.
And we think this
is important.
For example, when you need to
have the context of the page
underneath.
For example, if you have a blog
post and you want your
user to share the blog post,
it's probably important when
the user is interacting with the
service, that they can see
the blog post underneath in
order to say, hey, this is a
really cool article.
But please keep in mind that
it's not the client that gets
to say how the services open.
The service is the one that
knows how best to be opened.
So let's go to the
next major step.
Once your service is invoked,
what happens then?
Well, the data is sent on the
window.intent object.
And I'll talk about this here.
You'll notice that we have
webkit prefixing.
As we say often, this is still
an experimental API.
It's still going through
the wringer in the
standardization process.
And we want to make sure that
we're good web citizens.
And so, as we're changing the
API, once we get to a more
stable version, we can drop the
webkit prefix once we have
other browser vendors
implementing this as well.
And this is standard across
APIs that are evolving.
So you'll see here that we're
switching on Action and Type.
Now, if you're a simple service,
and you only register
for one piece of functionality,
one filter as
we call it, then you probably
don't need to do any switching
on the Action and the Type.
You know what data is
coming, you know
what service you doing.
But let's say you're more fully
function service, and
you've registered for
multiple filters,
multiple actions and types.
You're probably going
to want to switch
on how was I invoked?
Which action am I supposed
to be handling?
What's the type of data
that's coming in?
So here, we're saving, and we
know it's a ping, so the
intentobject.data is the actual
data that's sent from
the client.
Let's check out a debugger that
can help us see what data
is being passed back
and forth.
Now this is a nifty little
application that's available
on the Chrome Web Store.
It allows you, whether a service
or client page, to see
what data is sent in from
Intent invocation.
So we see, that when we invoked
this intent on the
page, we use the Save action and
we passed in the type of
URI listing.
And here is the actual data,
which is that link.
It's really nifty to be able to
debug and make sure that,
as a client, you're sending
the right data, and as a
service, if there's something
going on, you're not getting
the right data, you could
say, here's exactly
what's going wrong.
Now this is a Chrome
application, it's pretty nifty.
But long-term, longer down the
road, we'd really like to add
this functionality to
the Web Inspector.
Maybe through an Inspector
extension.
Thank you, Paul.
So we've talked about one
side of the coin.
Let's flip it.
How do you actually invoke
Intents as a client?
It's really simple.
You construct an intent object,
passing in the action
and the type and perhaps the
data that you want to send to
the service, and then you
call startActivity.
That actually invokes the flow
of Intents in the browser.
The picker UI will show up, as
you've seen in a couple times
that we've demoed.
The list of services that match
this filter on action
and type will show up.
And the user gets to
pick their choice.
Which service do they
want to use?
And you're done.
That's all you have
to do as a client.
It's ridiculously easy.
So we talked about one-way
communication.
You send data from the client
to the service.
But we need to be able to
transform data, we need to do
able to send data back.
We can do that.
We can have bi-bidirectional
communication.
So the API has two optional
callbacks, onSuccess being the
most important, which
is your 90% case.
When things go well
with the service.
This is the way the service will
send back data and how
you receive it, the onSuccess
callback back So as a service,
you call the postResult method
on the intent object that you
were sent in.
The intent object
being the link
between you and the client.
And you're probably going
to pass on the
data to this method.
There's also a non-failure
method, in case
something goes wrong.
It could be sent from the
browser, say there was a 404
with the service that
was picked.
Or, it could be sent from the
service in case perhaps the
data you sent from the client
didn't quite lineup, didn't
quite match what
they expected.
I mean, to be fair, we want
this case to never happen.
In well-behaved applications,
there are no failure states.
But you need to be realistic.
There are going to
be failures.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So we went over the
basics of the API.
The ability to start and invoke
and action, and then
the ability to actually respond
to that and deliver
the data to the user in the
format that they want inside
the other application,
and bring it back in.
So let's talk about how we can
build applications that love
each other.
How we can actually take this
basic API that we've just
shown you, and actually solve
the problems that we talked
about at the beginning
of the presentation.
So the first one
is pick, right?
And we have a pick intent,
http://webintents/org/pick.
We try to think of it
as, like, the file
opener to the web.
Normally on desktop
applications, we'll have a
File, Open menu where we'll be
able to scan the hard drive.
We should be able to pull in the
data from any web service
across the web that supports
the pick intent.
So let's have a quick example.
We'll pull in from the webcam.
So we got a little application
called Quicksnapr.
We're going to ask able to
wave, if that's possible.
That's it, cool.
Thank you very much.
And then we click on it,
bring it through.
Cool, right?
My presentation is not
an application.
It shouldn't have to have
complex file open
functionality just to be
able to bring that
data into this app.
And likewise, Quicksnapr, it
shouldn't have to know about
my presentation's integration
with its services.
So we've just brought
the data back in.
It's pretty cool, right?
As you've seen from the code
earlier on in this
presentation, there's three
or four lines of code.
The ability to instantiate a
webkit intent object or an
intent object, the data that
you want to use, the action
type, and then the
startActivity.
The startActivity
has onSuccess.
OnSuccess just basically takes
the data back in and then
attaches it to an image.
And that is pretty
much all it does.
We cache the image for related
use in some of the next
slides, and you'll
see what happens.
But what I what really want to
show you guys is actually this
is the set pattern.
The same pattern across every
single action that we're going
to try and do.
And hopefully this will show
you how simple it is to
integrate with this API.
So we've picked an image.
We need to edit it.
We need to maybe create an
inspirational message for the
rest of the world.
So let's use another demo
application we've made called
Inspirationmator.
And all it does is it creates
those inspirational photos.
It's not very complex.
It doesn't tend to be like
Photoshop or Pixelmator, or
any other type of application.
It just adds inspirational
text to photos.
Cool.
JAMES HAWKINS: All right.
Let's go back up.
PAUL KINLAN: We need to
get off the screen.
Click on it, and then--
Sorry about this, guys.
JAMES HAWKINS: There we go.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
So that's pretty cool, right?
We've had two applications
just talk with my
presentation.
That's pretty cool.
And if you look at the code,
it's exactly the same, apart
from, this time, we've change
the action to Edit.
So that means we're going to try
and find applications that
support the ability
to edit images.
And once the browser's found
them, it could be any type of
application, it doesn't have
to be Inspirationmator.
If the user hasn't got it
installed, they're not going
to see that on the list unless
it's one of the suggestions.
But we've managed to tend our
data out, edit it, and then
bring it back into our app.
And again, it's the same code.
We have an onSuccess callback
which takes the image data and
then just attaches
it to this image.
It's pretty cool, right?
So we've edited the data.
We want to make sure
it's all backed up.
So this is the Save intent.
If you look at the code, it's
exactly the same again.
Apart from this time,
we change the action
from Edit to Save.
So we're going to ask the
browser to find a list of
services that support
image saving.
So we're going to save back
out to Cloud File Picker.
So you remember that we pulled
in before, earlier in the
presentation, from my
Picasa account.
Well, we've actually just
saved it back out.
So if we just click View, just
to prove it's saved.
This is just using
the Drive API.
It's just a JavaScript API that
we chose to integrate
with for this demo.
But we've managed to upload
our application into the
user's cloud file storage
solution.
And if we click on it, we should
be able to view it.
And hey, there we are, right?
We've taken our data from one
application, brought into the
presentation, edited it in
another application, and then
saved it out to my preferred
cloud file storage solution.
It's pretty cool.
JAMES HAWKINS: There we go.
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you.
And obviously one of the things
that you want to do is
you want to tell the world how
cool this image is, right?
So we want to share.
Notice this doesn't have
an onSuccess callback.
My ability to share my
data to a service--
I don't need to know that
it's been shared, right?
Sometimes you might want to know
that the action has been
completed successfully, but in
this case, I don't, because I
don't actually need it.
So if we just share this image
out, we'll be able to share it
to a different service.
We'll just share to Imgur.
This is just using an API
integration with Imgur.
It's processing, we've saved,
and if we press the actual
link, we should, in theory, be
able to see it actually has
been push the web, and
we're not just kind
of making this up.
So, OK.
The user interface looks a
little bit hokey at the
moment, a bit crazy.
It's going to change
and improve.
It is an experimental API.
And as we iterate on this user
interface, it's going start to
look really nice.
JAMES HAWKINS: I want
to tell a little
anecdotal story about this.
So, for the longest time, we
couldn't get UX support, And
we were like, huh, what
can we do about this?
Engineer-built UI.
We built this, and then they're
like, oh my God, you
release with this.
Mocks, here you go, you have
all the mocks you need.
So we are actually polishing
up the UI, sanding down the
rough edges, and this is
going to look really
gorgeous really soon now.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
This is a nice demonstration
of an inline intent.
We still have the context of the
page that actually invoked
action behind, but we were able
to manipulate this image
inside this context.
It's pretty cool.
And, obviously, once you shared
it out, you've shared
it out of the world, you
get users viewing.
If a user views a link right
now, they either download the
data or just kind of view
inside the browser.
But what happens if they want
to use their preferred
application?
Right now, we don't have the
ability to say, open this
image with my preferred
application.
But we have got some
experimental support for RSS
and Atom feeds.
So I just want to show
you this, actually.
It's pretty cool.
So we have just a link
that is clicked.
There's no actual API
that's invoked.
The browser's detected that
actually, there's a content
type that I can handle via
the Intent system.
So it opens up the picker.
And we'll choose Feed Intent
Viewer, which is an
application that Mihai Parparita
wrote, which just
off is the same functionality
that you
would expect in Chrome.
Obviously, most users aren't
developers, and they won't use
this extension and
application.
They might use their preferred
feed reader, which is pretty
cool stuff.
And we have some other
examples, as well.
So these are intents that are
actually on the WebIntents.org
domain, and they manage
under that name space.
We have Subscribe.
The idea behind this is, if you
have a URL that you want
to, not view, but subscribe to
regular updates from in your
favorite feed reader, well
that's just a simple action
that says I'm going to subscribe
to this feed.
And then we have another
one for Shorten.
So the idea behind this is you
might have a link or some data
you want to compress.
In this case it's a link.
And we're going to shorten
it with the Google API.
It's pretty simple.
This doesn't look sexy because,
again, this is my own
demonstration.
But we've taken our data from
one application, sent it using
the Google API, JSON API that
you can interact with, and
saved it in this page.
And obviously we click Return,
we should be able to see the
data come back in.
So this demonstrates, even with
the inline context, you
can pass data in, manipulate it,
and bring it back out to
you application.
It's pretty cool, I think it's
pretty powerful stuff as well.
JAMES HAWKINS: So far we've
talked about a lot of
high-level integrations.
We've got the input and output
of data going on.
But there's more advanced
communication we could be doing.
Let's say that you're a
photo storage site.
You have users who have very
large raw photos, perhaps 50
megabytes, and your site
does not have editing
functionality.
Which is fine, because
we have Intents.
There are services out there
that will allow your user to
edit the image and pass back
the manipulated bits.
But what we have to do, we have
this blob, and that's
going to be copied.
It's 50 megabytes of data, it's
going to be copied, even
client-side just to the other
service so that they can have
the bits as well.
This is not cool.
Now we have a slow copy, a
slow synchronous copy.
We have a service and a client
that both have a
copy of the same data.
We want to solve this problem.
So we can which transferables.
We can transfer this blob.
What transferables allows you
to do is say, I have a large
set of data.
Just pass a reference.
We don't need to pass the
entire set of data.
The browser has a copy of the
data, just send a pointer to
it and say, this is where
your data is at.
The service that's editing
the image can perform the
manipulation on the bits, and
then return the result
transferred once again back to
the client, and the client has
the edited data.
No copying whatsoever,
just transferred.
Very fast.
Another important advancing you
can do with Intents are
explicit intent.
So your application may be
very well componentized.
You've got little bits of
functionality here.
Say, an email application has
composing emails, it has--
what else do we have, Paul,
in email applications?
Reading emails.
You've got a reading
email view.
PAUL KINLAN: Download.
Save.
JAMES HAWKINS: You've
got the inbox view.
And some of these things could
be shared with other
applications, such as
composing an email.
That could be a form of
sharing, if you will.
So you have registered for
Intents that you are a service
that handles sharing with your
Compose functionality.
But you can also call yourself
this way with the Intents API.
You could say, example.com, say,
which is my own service,
and call into your
own components
using the Intents API.
So let's say you're a client,
and you have some very,
perhaps, obscure action that
you need performed on your
data, or that you want the user
to be able to select.
But you don't want to have a
situation where the picker
shows up as empty.
Let's say we're in a world where
web pages can register
for Intents.
There are no Chrome applications
that can handle
this action.
You want to make sure that the
services that you know about
that can handle this action
are available to the user.
So we have suggestions, which
allow you to say, I know
example.com and another example
can handle this action.
So pass those in and show them
to the user to give them a
choice to select
these as well.
The alternative solution to the
problem of having an empty
picker, which is a horrible UX
experience for the user, is
having a way to say, is there
anything in the picker?
Is anything going to show up?
Are there services registered
that handle this action?
That's a no-no on the web,
because that allows
fingerprinting the user.
We didn't want to introduce
this to the web.
So we have suggestions here
for that use case.
So do for apps what links
did for the web.
Greg Billock said that.
Who's Greg Billock?
I know.
Now you're asking her.
Greg Billock is one of the lead
engineers on Intents.
He's right here in
the front row.
Yeah.
He's going to be doing a code
lab this afternoon, with
Rachel as well, which'll
be very interesting.
But what's important to think
about here is that links are a
one-to-one communication.
And that's what the
web is today.
Web Intents allow scaling to the
size of the web, where you
have one to "n." Your client
to many services.
And the most important thing
is that those "n" services
that can be chosen are
picked by the user.
They say, I like this site.
I like this service.
And I don't want to deal
with anything else.
There are 300 sharing
services out there.
Probably more that we don't
even know about.
But the user only cares
about three of them.
Only show them the services
they care about.
And Intents lets us do this.
It's also extremely
easy to use.
I feel like we've been showing
the exact same code for all of
these slides, almost
as filler, right?
But it's to say, it's
so easy to use.
It requires very little cost for
developers to integrate,
both on the client side
and as a service.
This is very important
for integration.
We want this ecosystem
to build up and to be
useful for the user.
PAUL KINLAN: So we're pretty
much finished now.
We do have some more
information, though.
So we have a selection
of links.
We have the W3C specification,
which is, like we said, in
first public working draft
at the moment.
You can go in there, if you
really want to know the
nitty-gritty about the API,
you can go there and
understand everything
that's happening.
We also have some high-level
documentation.
That's the whole point of
WebIntents.og and all the
actions underneath that, is
that we can provide more
developer-friendly documentation
about how you're
supposed to interact with these
services, and examples,
demos, and a whole lot
of other things.
We also have a Google+
Web Intense account.
So it's +Web Intents.
If you just want to follow it,
we'll be doing updates.
We'll be sharing these slides
at the end, as well.
But also, if we find any great
applications, tutorials, and
articles, we'll share that
through there as well.
Because we want you, as
developers, to be able to
understand what the rest of
the ecosystem is actually
building and doing through
this system.
Likewise, there's a high-level
discussion group.
It's not the specification
discussion group, if the
application developers
discussion group.
So if you want to know how to
integrate with Save, maybe to
save a Word document or
something similar, and you're
having troubles, and you want
to find out whether other
developers are doing something
similar, that's
the place to go.
Because that'll be application
developers inside that space.
And likewise, with every single
demo that we've seen
today, they're all open-source
and available on github.com
under /PaulKinlan/WebIntents,
so you can go and play.
We do have a code lab.
So I actually do want
to ask one question.
Is everyone excited
about the API?
[APPLAUSE]
JAMES HAWKINS: All
right, Sweet.
PAUL KINLAN: Cool.
Thank you.
So, we do have the code lab,
as James said before.
It's 1:45 to 3:45, code lab room
one, where Rachel Blum
and Greg Billock will actually
take you through the API if
you haven't got an
application.
However, if you do have web
applications that you want to
integrate with Intents, come
and speak to us, and we'll
show you how we think you should
integrate that into the
Intents system.
So we want to get this really
cool ecosystem going, and
we're there to help you guys.
We've got a whole lot of other
technical assistants.
And just before I finish, this
is a family thing for me.
It's my son's birthday today.
So I'd just like to say, happy
birthday Benjamin!
Sorry I couldn't be there,
I'll be there later.
And everyone's going to
sing Happy Birthday.
No?
OK, maybe later.
So anyway, thank you.
So we'd like to go forth
and intentify.
That's my joke, and I'm
very sorry for this.
Likewise, we have the Web
Intents Google+ account.
We are both on Google+ as
well, under our names.
If you have any questions,
comments, or feedback, we'd
just love to get as much
as you want now.
Either here, outside in the
hallway, or we'll be in the
office hours area as well
for a couple of hours.
Thank you very much.
JAMES HAWKINS: And we are
open for questions.
AUDIENCE: Is there a way to
whitelist or blacklist the
items that show up?
We make medical software,
and so, in the US, there
regulations about privacy.
So we couldn't just open it up
for any application to share.
But there are unknown number
of ones that would be
acceptable.
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
Not actually directly
inside Chrome or
the Chrome Web Store.
The actual list, the main list
that you see, are only
applications that you've
directly installed.
So we don't have a policy
at the moment inside
Chrome for Chrome OS.
JAMES HAWKINS: So you
could use explicit
intents for that purpose.
If you know the list in advance,
you can make use of
the Intents API in order to call
them directly, especially
if that list is small.
And suggestions as
well, right?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
One thing.
The list of intents that you
could call was basically the
list of applications that you
had installed that replied to
those intents.
But how would that go
for web intents?
For intents that are
on the website?
Is there some form of discovery,
like the sites you
visited that--
JAMES HAWKINS: Exactly.
That's exactly what it is.
So we feel that the user
visiting a site is a very
strong signal.
One, of many, that they
want to have this
available as a service.
And we also think we're going
to have to be smart about
heuristics to say, what
services does a
user want to see?
So you're exactly right.
And as the user's browsing
around, there could be a
problem where they just
aggregate all these services,
and they don't care about
most of them.
We think it's really up to the
browser, and we're going to
try to do the job of this
to make it a great user
experience and to understand
exactly what they want to see.
We also have the malware
database, the safe browsing
database, that we can use to
say, this is spam, this
service should definitely
not be seen.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm kind of new for this field,
and I have two questions.
One is, can you show a couple
samples of how the UI looks
like for the explicit
and suggest intents?
JAMES HAWKINS: So I can talk
about explicit intents.
For explicit intents, the
picker does not show up.
It will go directly
to the site in the
disposition that they want.
So if it's Window, it will
open in the new tab.
If it's Inline, will show--
you saw the service pull down,
and it will just be
displayed in there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
The other one is so are there
any other objects which can be
used for to startActivity
function?
JAMES HAWKINS: For Share?
AUDIENCE: For the
startActivity.
JAMES HAWKINS: Oh,
AUDIENCE: Yeah
JAMES HAWKINS: It's just the
intent object and the
parameters as specified
in the API.
AUDIENCE: Because the name
is it more generic.
StartActivity.
JAMES HAWKINS: Right.
So the name actually came from
Android Intents, which Web
Intents is based off of.
And we felt it was important
for a developer mind share
that we have an entire ecosystem
of apps built on
Android Intents, and that's a
large developer base of people
that know Intents.
So as we were developing this
API, we said, let's pick and
pull pieces that we think are
important from Android Intents
that people will be used to.
The name is almost kind of--
it's not arbitrary, but there
are multiple things we
could have picked.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks a lot.
AUDIENCE: So on Android Intents,
I find that sometimes
I find the list is so long,
because the action is so
generic, like Share, that it's
cumbersome for the user.
So going back, kind of, to
heuristics, do you have the
intent to let the user select
a default intent for
a given MIME type?
JAMES HAWKINS: Yeah.
That's one thing that we are
diverging from Android Intents
as it stands now, which is
to have smart defaulting.
And we're working out the
kinks on that now.
Actually, I'm going to point
and embarrass her.
Rachel is actually owning
that functionality.
The red head down here,
you'll see here her at
the code lab later.
RACHEL BLUM: Sorry.
JAMES HAWKINS: No, no,
no, no apologies.
We're working on it.
So it should be out
in probably maybe
our next stable release.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
And the stuff you showed us
today, is that from Canary?
PAUL KINLAN: Stable.
I was on Canary, but most of the
API's already in stable.
JAMES HAWKINS: It looks
like on stable, the
latest stable release.
AUDIENCE: Great, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
prognosis on when we will be
able to use Web Intense
in major browsers?
JAMES HAWKINS: It's
difficult to say.
So, we're working with all the
other browser vendors through
the W3C in the standardization
process.
And that conversation is very
vibrant, lots communication on
the public Web Intense mailing
list, which is where all this
is happening on the W3C.
So I think, in order to get a
better feel for that, a gist
of it, I would probably
join that mailing
list and see for yourself.
PAUL KINLAN: We also do have a
JavaScript shim, which at the
moment is binary-compatible,
for other browsers.
For instance, Mozilla, Firefox,
Internet Explorer 8
and upwards, and
Opera as well.
We don't want the shim to exist,
ideally we want better
solutions everywhere else.
But we do have a shim to
replicate the functionality at
the moment in other browsers.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Will we see Web
Intents offered up by the
Android Chrome browser
as Android Intents?
JAMES HAWKINS: That's
a good question.
We absolutely want to do that.
It's much further down
on the road map.
It's a very tricky
problem to solve.
It requires work on both the
browser side and major
additions to the Android
side as well.
So we're working on
those problems.
It probably won't be out
for quite while, on
the order of months.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Is it possible to customize
somehow to picking dialogue of
the applications?
Because if I have my application
and I have some
UI, I don't want to have
this now ugly dialogue.
JAMES HAWKINS: Yes.
Well, I'll answer that
part of it first.
We're trying to make
it not ugly.
But we've always had this idea
that we can add an extension
API for an extension to
manipulate how the picker may
look or all the elements
on the picker.
That's a tricky problem
to solve as well.
We've got to make sure it's
secure, that the extension's
not mucking with things
in a bad way.
But we want to do that.
That is also longer down
on the road map.
AUDIENCE: Will there be
some kind of API to
programmatically get a
list of [INAUDIBLE]
for given intents,
like an Android?
JAMES HAWKINS: Not
for the web.
Chrome extensions and Chrome
apps obviously have elevated
permissions through
that system.
That could be something that
we could expose there.
But we definitely would not
allow that for the web for
issues of fingerprinting.
AUDIENCE: Is there anything
baked in for nice backwards
compatibility or
downgradability, or is that on
us to figure out?
JAMES HAWKINS: As far as?
AUDIENCE: Well for file picker,
I want to provide the
Web Intent capability in my
client, but if they're on a
browser that doesn't support it
or whatever, is it just on
me to detect and
build that out?
PAUL KINLAN: This is one area
that we were talking about and
we still need to go through the
specification groups, is
how could we potentially
manipulate some of the
existing elements in HTML, like
file pick, so that you
could just say, I'm going to
pull a file in from the cloud
and then it goes that way.
I don't see it as
particularly--
correct me if I'm wrong-- but
I don't see it as trying to
make the existing API downgrade
to an existing pick.
You'd have a pick that's
optimized and enhanced with
the Intents service,
if that make sense.
JAMES HAWKINS: So there is
one thing you can do.
You can check for
the existence of
AUDIENCE: Webkit [INAUDIBLE].
JAMES HAWKINS: --startActivity.
Yeah, webkit startActivity.
If it's not there, then the
API's not there for whatever
browser is there.
PAUL KINLAN: And modernizer's
got to check in
for that, as well.
JAMES HAWKINS: Modernizer,
yeah.
There's also things that we're
adding to the browser.
We're trying to sort of
bootstrap the ecosystem in a
way by having the browser
be a client.
So for picking files, we could
say, show the file picker so
you can pick something from
your file system, which is
provided by the browser.
The user doesn't know that
it's not a service.
It just works for them, right?
So we're trying to find more
points of integration in the
browser for it to be a client.
AUDIENCE: Cool, cool.
OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Is it possible to
do metrics collection?
Just figure out what intents
are more popular, or--
JAMES HAWKINS: We are actually
adding metrics through our UMA
API, our User Metrics
API in Chrome.
We're not exactly sure yet, we
haven't quite designed exactly
what type of data we're
trying to get back.
Obviously, bucketing
on the major
action types is important.
But our current API is limited
in that we wouldn't be able to
create buckets for things
we don't know about.
So we're trying to think
through that.
Let's see, maybe some service
that example.com created, the
functionality that they create
is really popular.
We'd actually like to
know about that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
OK.
Thank you.
PAUL KINLAN: The other side of
that is the actual Web Store
itself, it index and archives
every application that's got
its functionality declared
by the manifest.
And if you click on, there's a
little link at the bottom of
the intent picker where
you can click
to find more services.
You get a good education about
the usage and availability of
support services at least for
those types of actions.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So, related to that,
that would be where I, as a
developer, discover which other
applications are web
content enabled?
JAMES HAWKINS: Right.
That's Find More Services
link that you'll see.
Yeah.
And we show that whenever there
are more services than
we show in the picker.
AUDIENCE: But if I as the
developer wanted, for example,
to integrate with Google
Calendar or other services
that might or might not
be Web Intent enabled.
Is there an easy resource
for me to access
to see which services--
PAUL KINLAN: Right now it's
through the Chrome Web Store.
Through that area.
One of my goals with the Web
Intents documentation was to
be able to, if we have the
index, the intent tag, is that
we can do queries on the
web, essentially.
To then go, well these are the
list of service that we know
that support this, and
have it shown in the
documentation up front.
We're way away from that
for the moment.
The Chrome Web Store is
the way to go for
understanding what--
JAMES HAWKINS: Yeah, I mean
you can imagine this.
Intent is really important for
the web, and we're here as
citizens of the web for Intents,
but we also work for
a search engine.
A major search engine.
So once the Intent tag is out
there, we have this ability to
crawl the web and say, who
actually supports Intents?
So I don't know if it's
something that we'll add to
search, or whether some
other crawl mechanism.
But it would be awesome if we
had a database of sites that
support Intents that
was updated
automatically, et cetera.
And you could go to their
sites and see what their
actions actually are.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I think there is
currently a limitation in the
way actions are triggered.
It only is by user movement--
JAMES HAWKINS: User gesture.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But that leads to a problem
where, currently, you cannot
have them working with Chrome
extension that are actually
contextual menus or
just patterns.
Because even though they are
triggered by user action, the
window showing up is actually
not technically a user action.
Is it something that's
going to be sold, or?
JAMES HAWKINS: A bug!
You found a bug.
I thought we had zero.
PAUL KINLAN: It's exists.
The bug is open and
tracked by Greg.
We call it Bug Greg.
It's a thing I want
to as well.
It'd be nice.
AUDIENCE: Is the goal of
WebIntents.org to be sort of
authoritative source about all
the intents that are available
out there, and is there
a submission process.
What's that about?
PAUL KINLAN: Yeah.
So the idea behind
WebIntents.org is, when we
started this off before we were
going to go in through
the W3C standardization,
was it's not complete
authoritative, exhaustive list
of every single possible
intent that's out on the web.
It's just a very core set of
use cases that we wanted to
try and solve right now.
And as we saw more use cases
come in, we might take you
into the stewardship of
WebIntents.org and have that
as the de facto.
However, it's quite early
on this whole ecosystem.
So we might get a payment
solution, provided that
there's a pay intent,
for instance.
And that becomes the de facto
standard that everyone uses
inside that URL.
And that never comes under the
stewardship of WebIntents.org.
It's under their stewardship
to maintain a standard and
everything.
So I didn't personally want it
to be authoritative and index,
knock out every single thing on
the web and every different
type of intent, but it depends
on how the standardization
goes as well.
Because the W3C we're talking
about maybe you should
formalize some of the actual
core intents right now.
Get that whole process underway
through that group.
AUDIENCE: So is there as
submission process currently
in WebIntents.org?
PAUL KINLAN: There is a
contributor's guide, where we
basically say, go to this
discussion group, we'll talk
about the different types
of use case that you
want to try and solve.
And if we have at least one
client, potentially, and one
service that are going to be
able to do it and handle it,
then we can probably try to
standardize it a little bit
more inside of WebIntents.org
But again, we haven't done
that yet, because no one's
come to us with an idea
outside of use case we've
had originally.
JAMES HAWKINS: We're open.
And we'll see how it goes from
there, I think, is the answer.
JAMES HAWKINS: So there's
a site right now called
OpenIntents.org, which predates
Web Intents, and it's
actually for Android Intents.
And they have this database
on their site
which is really awesome.
It was one of the big things,
when we started Web Intents, I
was like, aw, man, this
is really cool.
We want services to come up with
all these functionalities
that we could never
even dream of.
And have a way that developers
can find them.
So I think WebIntents.org may
eventually end up hosting some
database that lists these, and
there's an easy submission
process that's very low
cost for developers
to add their actions.
I mean, it doesn't really hurt
anyone for this database to
exist, as long as you have ways
to support and prioritize
and expose the best services,
or the best actions.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
Are microformats a good
candidate for a type of thing
to use on Web Intents?
JAMES HAWKINS: Absolutely
AUDIENCE: Cool.
PAUL KINLAN: You just have to
get the type right, and then
as long as the two services
agree that they can transport
the same data, you could pass
a blob of HTML through.
And then both services
could parse it out.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have another question.
Is there a plan at some point
to use Web Intents
for the Chrome UI?
For example, the Print
button, could it
trigger a Print intent?
The star to favorite site
could be used--
JAMES HAWKINS: Absolutely.
Yep.
So that was what I was referring
to earlier, about
trying to find integration
points.
Another one that we could do
very easily is, say, adding
things to context menus.
So, if you know the context,
you know exactly
what you can do.
Say you right click on an image,
there are a lot of
things you can do with images.
And we can be smart about that
and say, all right, I want to
share this image, I want
to edit this image,
or save this image.
And not just your hard drive,
obviously, but to
the cloud as well.
So yeah, we want to add these
integration points.
AUDIENCE: That'd be amazing.
JAMES HAWKINS: Anybody else?
All right.
Thank you very much
PAUL KINLAN: Thank you.